we have to get to this week's hatred
mail hatred mail is when a professional
voice-over artist does interpretive
readings of the really whacked-out
hatred mail that I get here's a quick
reminder about hatred mail it's like a
mandatory transvaginal ultrasound for
your mind Patriot Man written by
Patriots who hate David Pakman because
America and because freedom I this is a
shameful week for hatred mail you'll see
what I mean in a second take a look do
you remember this thing called the
Constitution and how every president of
it's obeys it I'm ash Hamid to say used
to think parks min was liggett's
this post proves he's out to shill to
get hips your bigoted and you're a shill
636 K mold no chance in hell 636 K
subscripts don't just leave social media
leave your show yeah I would be a
shammed to send in a message like that
to a program knowing that it's possible
that it might make it onto the air and
the best thing you can do if you are
it's funny hatred mail motivates you
know I go on these rants about
membership culture and supporting the
media that we want and disconnecting
advertisers support from the financial
viability of programs that we like in
all of this stuff and yeah some people
get motivated to sign up for membership
with that the amount of people that sign
up as a result of hatred mail is
stunning it's almost like I should just
play a hatred mail every week and we
would have significantly more membership
signups because the best way to fight
hate reott ism is to go to our website
david pakman.com slash membership and
sign up with the coupon code hatred for
th8 e RI o t40
when you do that you save 40% off of
your membership and it's like a double
middle finger to the hey tree it's
telling the
you can say whatever you want but we are
here and we are supporting progressive
independent media at least that's how I
interpret it when someone signs up on
our website with the coupon code hey
tree at 40 I invite you to do the exact
same thing